welcome to this video playing GM endless
fighter indian flag former bangladesh
flag and always tough against this guy
Scott I've got three wins four losses
and at least I've got a slight head
start on time he it took her to commit
it to cook 20 seconds to to get going
the Trump polski or maybe John pawelski
is it term that's the pronounced
pronunciation in English before yes this
recently count came into fashion yeah
it's a very weird line I don't really
know it have no idea takes is going to
play a five g5 Bishop g3 something very
strange stuff but I saw this i saw this
recently in a book quite weird but it's
a it's such a such a crazy position that
and this time blitz at certainly very
much viable okay he wants to take i'm
not sure that i want to recapture with
the Queen
now I don't know it looks it looks
dangerous this position
yeah I mean where am I going to put my
king can try to Castle Queen side it's
not so easy to accomplish I mean yeah if
he takes there now okay it's it's it's a
terrible structure but at least this
pawn is covering E for NC 4 which is
worse something I mean the night on d 2
is not not especially great I don't I
don't mind that structure so much unless
ur I'm losing d5 quickly this would be
terrible of course I don't know maybe
Queen f3 something like that okay i
wonder if i should play Queen a five and
just to attack the a pond and make it
difficult for him to Castle long and b6
Bishop a six is actually quite an idea
yeah let's do that whether it's not too
bad
ok so it's intending to go to to f5 or
2h7 maybe night before hmm now let's do
that and let's consider i mean i can
play a move like Queen B 5 is going to
do casal long I really feel that I
should here here there should be
something good in this position
something good to play
I talk about talk about a difficult
position come on we need to claim here I
cannot really fit assess this correctly
let's just castle and here it's hot it's
hard to play be sure before maybe still
one left there's some point in keeping
this square for one night but okay I'm
threatening g4 at least Andrew gave a
Droog f3 probably even a small now it's
also not at all easy for him to play
well what what should he do here Castle
long I take a two we cannot Castle short
a 3 is not really threatening anything
and I'm threatening g4 yeah but it was
it was probably quite okay for me what
is this night be three coming maybe
I don't know is the three of us we can
play C 3 maybe come in a form intending
that I'm very hard to play I can take d
for even which I didn't really consider
now I didn't see that you can take one
default
even this isn't isn't entirely clear but
I probably had a very good position
before that check here check time
morning I jig on c3 or you can also play
Bishop e3 this is maybe even better
Bishop DC three days maybe look T 1 now
I'm threatening Quincy 3
Wow
what a rocky position and I don't I
don't really see a defense really takes
Queen takes Knight check check
queen bee three maybe look to c 8 i need
to look on c8 battle check sir rook c8
coming check check check check check
check check check check mate oh who have
no idea what was going on in this game
what deck it was just like hand-to-hand
combat I mean my suspicion is that that
black is very good here but it's it's so
murky yeah if you look at this the
computer is just not only giving minus
two but play it it's not easy be sure
before what's what's correct even and
now what what now the computer gives
rook g2f aids with with the wind basic
lame and then queen bee five I played
this one you know what I completely
overlooked is that he can actually take
before I didn't see that at all Wow
computer suggestion here's rook h8 rook
h8 isn't this funny no yeah okay that's
a check made on h1 like that check
checkmate
so I wants to play here I'm not like
here and then then play this with the
good position but okay I mean this this
is given a sequel but here okay bishops
III is winning yeah I wasn't I wasn't so
sure if it is really winning actually I
didn't calculate here I was giving the
check instantly check with the time time
limited you do you like to give those
check but this is just better yeah this
is just better the thing is I get had
given the check and here I noticed that
she has got rooked you one and this is
in fact good for wide and of course if I
take take here it's it's the same
business I mean if he takes AI transpose
to this and just win so um this is this
is the problem the bishop 83 was it was
a good one but it's a yeah it is in fact
winning as well okay yeah you can all
only play these shots and hope that
their work what I could i calculated of
course is this line and this is in fact
really winning there's no way to cover
c2 he played this check check and now
Bishop me sadness the computer move okay
even having Bishop g5 fair this is
strong I played this one which which
seems to be lk he's got 26 now now this
would have been would have been really a
bit disappointing if he had found that
Queen d6 check but ok this is this is
winning again with rook c8 coming
and even rook c8 years possible okay
this is the easiest wow what a game
thanks for watching